le Rafal c'est le nom du nouvel avion de
combat français présenté par la firme
Marcel d'assaau qui entre ainsi
directement en concurrence avec l'avion
de combat européen construit par
l'Angleterre l'Allemagne fédérale et
l'Espagne Laurent
Boussier un nouvel avion c'est toujours
un événement surtout quand il s'agit
d'un avion de combat qui comme le Rafal
a déjà bien avant son premier vol fait
couler autant d'encre ce matin dans les
ateliers d'assaut à saint-clou c'était
l'effervescence h chaînes de télévision
européennes américaine des journalistes
du monde entier découvraient le digne
successeur du Mirage 3 et du Mirage
2000 il faut dire qu'il a de quoi
séduire ce rafale avec sa silhouette
agressive son empenage canard et sa
structure en matériaux composites aussi
performant que le lithium la fibre de
carbone et le Kevlar autre nouveauté
particulièrement attendu son système
d'armes et de guidage ses commandes de
vol électrique et son système de
contrôle automatique lu de comre Mme en
cas de flash nucléire ou de contesure
électronique et puis il y a aussi ces
performance avion de la classe Mac grâce
à ces de réacteurs il pourra arracher du
soles 14utomne en moins de 500 mer
frapper aveces missiles des objectifs
situés à 600 km et revenir se poser sur
une piste ou sur une portion
d'autoroute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin pour s'adapter aux performance de
son avion le pilote disposera d'un
cockpit entièrement nouveau c'est ce
prototype qui devrait voler pour la
première fois en mai ou juin prochain il
a pour l'instant plus de 6 mois d'avance
sur son concurrent anglais et il ne
semble pas très préoccupé par les
discussions politiques
franco-européennes qui le
concernent M